Boris Johnson ha dicho que el gobierno
irá más lejos y más rápido para
maximizar las oportunidades del brexit
pero lo cierto es que aún falta mucho
por negociar con la Unión Europea con
Bruselas se espera que Johnson cumplan
las promesas de campaña una de ellas
mostrar los beneficios de ser un país
independiente de la Unión Europea ha
dicho en las últimas horas el primer
ministro que uno de estos beneficios es
el la vacunación contra el covid-19 la
que el Reino Unido lleva la delantera
frente a la Unión Europea pero la gente
espera más además de acordar nuevos
tratados de libre comercio con países
importantes como con Estados Unidos pero
por ahora Joe Biden ha mantenido cerrada
esa puerta lo cierto es que los
analistas han advertido que el Reino
Unido está viviendo un periodo de
adaptación y de transición y que no hay
certeza de saber todavía cuál es el
impacto real del brexit en la economía
británica también golpeada por la
pandemia del covid 19